Good morning. So, today we start
the Bible,
which will be the final unit before the
semester break.
Hopefully, this will be the most
interesting
section we do.
It's certainly the most important
because the Bible is the most important
book
uh ever.
And it is driving a lot
It has driven a lot of history. It's
driving a lot of history today. So, if
you want to fully understand the
conflict in the Middle East, what's
happening between Israel and Iran,
uh what's happening in Palestine, you
cannot do so without a full
understanding
of the Bible.
At the same time, the Bible is
um because it's so important,
the ideas around it are very
controversial.
There are billions of people around the
world who believe the Bible is the word
of God. It's holy scripture.
Every word in the Bible comes to us from
uh divine uh the divinity himself.
And obviously, that's not what I
believe.
Um
more so,
I'm going to make arguments in this
class that go against not only the
traditional understanding of the Bible,
but also the mainstream academic
understanding of the Bible.
So,
um
to be fair
uh to you,
um I want you to be very skeptical of
what I say.
Okay? Come to class with doubting
my authority, doubting uh my
understanding of the Bible.
Okay? So, feel free to challenge me, and
I want you to challenge me
um because what I will say in this class
um is will be extremely controversial.
Okay?
So,
let me give you a brief introduction to
the Bible.
Um and then I'll explain some of the
history behind the Bible, okay? And this
overview is going to be very broad, very
general, but it'll help structure
the our understanding of the Bible for
the next few classes, okay?
All right. So, the Bible.
The Bible is Greek for books.
And it really means library.
So, the first thing you need to
understand is the Bible it's a
collection
of different works
by many different authors.
So, there's no
world view or consistency or continuity
in the Bible.
You can find whatever you want in the
Bible because it's it's such a it's a
library. It's a huge collection
um of ideas. There's about 2,000 pages.
Okay? So, there's very few people who
actually read the Bible
in its entirety. There are people who
might read certain sections of the
Bible.
Okay? But, most people will only will
receive their understanding of the Bible
from authorities like priests or rabbis,
okay?
Um the the Bible itself is divided into
two major sections. The first section is
what we call the Hebrew Bible.
And so, this was originally written in
Hebrew.
And this was This is the major This is
the book of the Jews, okay? What do the
Jews believe? They believe in the Hebrew
Bible.
The Hebrew Bible itself is divided into
three major sections. The first is uh
so, uh
so, the
Hebrew term for the Bible is the Tanakh.
Okay? So, you may hear hear some people
say the Tanakh. It just means the Hebrew
Bible, okay? The Tanakh is T N K. And
this this is uh the Hebrew term for
certain ideas. Uh the T stands for Torah
or teachings.
So, this is the laws
of the Jewish tradition.
Okay? For example, the 10 Commandments,
right?
Second is N, which means prophets.
Or uh and the prophets it themselves are
divided into minor and major.
So, in Rome,
um the people who are most admired are
the generals, right? Julius Caesar,
Pompey.
In Greece, the people who are most
admired are the poets, Homer and the
playwrights.
In the Jewish tradition, the people who
are most admired are the prophets.
Uh these individuals who speak the truth
of God. They're social critics and
they're people who challenge the uh
authority of the kings in order to
promote um the laws and teachings of
God. Does that make sense? The prophets
are the the people who are most admired
in the Jewish tradition.
And the third are K is writings. So,
basically, things that don't really
belong in teachings and prophets, but
which have some cultural or religious
significance to the Jewish people.
Okay?
So, this is the
Hebrew Bible.
And then we get to the New Testament,
which is something that only Christians
believe.
All right? So, Jewish people do not
accept anything in the New Testament.
The New Testament
calls the Hebrew Bible the Old
Testament.
Okay? Why? Because the Old Testament is
the promise
of salvation.
Okay, the promise of Jesus Christ.
The New Testament is the deliverance or
fulfillment of this promise in Jesus
Christ, okay? It's a coming and the work
of Jesus Christ. New Testament itself is
divided to many different works. It's
lots It's a lot
um smaller than the Old Testament. So,
there are the Gospels.
The Gospels is Greek for the
um good word.
And the good news is that Jesus is on
Earth and he's here to deliver us from
our sins and our suffering.
Uh there's letters.
Uh mainly by someone named Paul.
And these are the work of Jesus'
apostles
um after the death of Jesus. They go
around the world and they promote the
Gospel of Jesus, the the good news.
Okay? And this is about what they do.
And then there's something called
There's some other books as well, but
the major one is called Revelation.
Um which is about the end of the world.
And this idea of the second coming.
How even though Jesus is dead, um he
will return and he will bring peace,
eternal peace, to the world.
Now, from the Bible, interpretation of
the Bible comes the Quran.
And this is the basis for Islam. Okay?
So, eventually we'll do all three. The
Hebrew Bible, the New Testament, and the
Quran. But we'll start with
the
um Old Testament, the Hebrew Bible.
Okay?
Um so,
the Old Testament, the Hebrew Bible, is
what we'll start with.
And to do so, I will have to teach you a
lot of history. And this history will be
extremely broad.
Okay? But over time, I will be more
precise. I will go into specific details
about this history in order for you to
better understand the Bible. Okay?
Um
There are three ideas about the Hebrew
Bible
that Jews believe
that Jews today believe, which are not
true.
Okay?
The first idea is the Hebrew Bible, the
Jewish religion has always been
monotheistic.
Meaning
the Jews have always believed in one
God. His name is Yahweh.
And he is the God
of the Jews since Abraham, who is the
patriarch of all Jewish people.
Okay? That's what Jews believe. I will
show you this is not true.
In the beginning
Jewish people, like everyone else, were
uh what were polytheistic.
Okay?
Monotheistic is a modern idea
that has been retroactively
um put back into Jewish history.
Okay? So, that's the first
myth
that I will correct. The second myth
that I correct is
that
Jewish history or the Jewish religion
has been continuous
for at least 3,000 years, possibly 4,000
years.
Okay?
And what I will show you is that's not
true.
And so, there have been many major
changes to the religion.
At least changes are so drastic
that you can argue
these are very different people, okay?
So,
um the Israelites, the people who
founded the religion, are very different
from the people we call Jews today. And
I will show you why in the next few
classes, okay? Let's That's one really
important idea you need to understand.
The history of the Israelites and the
Jewish people are not continuous.
All right?
Okay?
Does that make sense?
Okay, any any any questions so far?
Are you guys following along?
Okay.
Um
Um yeah, so the last idea is
the Bible or the Hebrew Bible is a
historical record.
And what I will show you is
um
we've been trying for at least 300 years
200 years to to prove that the Bible is
a historical record. Okay, there are
archaeologists who've spent fortunes,
entire lifetimes, looking for things
like Noah's Ark. Looking for people like
Moses.
Can't find them, okay? And this tells us
pretty conclusively that the Bible is
not a historical record. It is a work of
our imagination.
Okay? It is It is a literary work.
Now, it's a very powerful literary work
and that's what explains
its relevance
and its power today, okay? I'll explain
why it's powerful, but I want you to
remember it's not a historical work. It
is a literary work. It's a work of our
collective imagination.
All right?
Okay. Now, I'm going to talk a little
about the broad history of the Israelite
people.
Okay? Um so,
in the Bible, what it tells you is maybe
about 2,000
uh BCE there's a man named Abraham.
And he's a from the city of, uh,
uh, Eric, okay?
In Mesopotamia. Or is it Ur? Okay, it's
it's one of the two, sorry.
Um, and then God, Yahweh,
thought Abraham
was the best man in the world.
So, God, Yahweh, made a covenant with
Abraham and said, "You are the most
righteous and dignified man I've ever
seen in the world, and I will make you a
father of a new nation called Israel."
Okay?
And these people will become eventually
the Israelites.
And the greatest king of the Israelites
is named David.
And then David, and then God says to
David,
"David, you are
the greatest man I've ever seen. I love
you as you love me.
Therefore, I will make your house, the
house of David, eternal."
Okay? "You, the house of David, will
reign over Israel for all of eternity. I
will make Israel into the mightiest of
nations."
Okay?
So, that is what it says in the Bible.
The historical record is a lot more
complicated.
All right?
So, let's start in the year
1200 BCE.
And this is
towards the end of the Bronze Age,
right? We're about to enter the Bronze
Age collapse, which lasts about 400
years.
At this time,
let's look at the world.
Israel is is is is is in a place called
the Levant.
And the Lo- Levant has always been
important because, as we discussed in
previous classes, Levant was one of the
first centers of agriculture. So,
Jericho is in the Levant.
But, it's also important because the
Levant is where three major
civilizations and empires meet, okay?
They are the crossroads or the nexus of
empire. These three empires are Egypt,
which again for most of its human
history has been the wealthiest and the
most powerful nation, okay?
Over here is Mesopotamia,
which is the cradle of civilization.
This is where
um human civilization
first developed mathematics, writing,
astronomy,
architecture, okay?
And up here are the Hittites
or Anatolia.
And Anatolia again is extremely wealthy.
So, the Levant is sort of sandwiched
between three extremely aggressive,
wealthy,
um and powerful nations that
that are extremely advanced and
sophisticated.
So, the Levant
um
has always been a colony
of either Egypt or Anatolia,
okay? Ver- it's it it's not been very
independent
for very long and it can't be because
it's at the edge of empire.
But, because of its position, okay? The
Levant is what we call a melting pot
or a meeting place.
So, every culture, every language, every
religion that was imaginable at this
time
met in the Levant, okay?
Mainly for trade purposes, right?
Because again, Egypt and Mesopotamia are
extremely wealthy. From the Levant, you
can go across the Mediterranean
into all of Europe and into northern
Africa.
Okay? So, the Levant was really the
center of the world
for most of its history.
And so, it was a meeting place mainly
for traders.
Right?
Um at this time,
uh Levant was divided into different
sections. A A province called Canaan
was a province of Egypt. And Canaan was
special to Egypt because the Egyptians
loved two things. They loved wine
and they loved olive oil.
And the Levant was very good at
um harvesting both wine good wine and
olive oil.
So,
um
but the Egyptians didn't really like
to go outside Egypt.
So, the people administrating the Levant
were local elites tied to Egypt, but
also foreign mercenaries.
And these foreign mercenaries were from
as far as Greece.
Okay? And we know this because we've
discovered
um Greek pottery
that dates back to this period.
These foreign mer- mercenaries would
then intermarry with the local woman
because as you can imagine, these are
young
uh males.
Okay?
You also had lots of nomads
living in the Levant because of Arabia,
right?
Okay? Lots of nomad people we call the
Bedouins.
You also had people living in the hills
of the Levant,
uh the hill people. Then you have these
cities.
Okay?
The um the Canaanites.
You also had, believe it or not,
Egyptian priests living in this area.
Why would they live in this area?
Well, because
they had a certain religion
that
was considered heretical
or controversial in Egypt, so they'd
have to leave to practice their
religion.
Or maybe they were priests who got into
a political struggle, and as such they
were exiled to the Levant.
Okay?
So, does that make sense?
The Levant, it's not at this point a
nation. At this point, it's really a
meeting place, a melting pot
of cultures, languages, and religions.
It's as It's diverse as can be. And
historically, this has always been the
case.
Right?
Then, what happened, of course,
is um is the Bronze Age collapse.
The thing with the Bronze Age collapse
is you have this massive migration of
people looking for food.
Right? These are called the Sea Peoples.
They're basically pirates.
And this And like there are these
massive waves of Sea Peoples attacking
the Hittites, attacking the Levant, and
attacking Egypt. And again, these are
like refugees.
Okay? This is a forced migration,
and they're trying to feed their
families.
They basically overrun the Hittites.
They destroy the cities of the Levant.
And they're They almost destroy Egypt,
but Egypt, because it's so wealthy,
is able to hold off
the Sea Peoples.
Eventually, what happens is the Sea
Peoples and Egypt come to an agreement
and say, "Listen, stop attacking us, and
we'll give you land in the Levant. You
can settle down there. You can grow your
own food. You can feed your families."
Okay?
And this place is what we call
Philistia.
And this is what And the And this
particular Philistines. So, these are
basically
um see the sea peoples, mainly Greek,
actually. There are a lot of Greeks
among the Philistines.
But, this creates a problem for everyone
in the Levant because now you have a
foreign messing Sorry, you have a
foreign presence that is very aggressive
and expansionist.
Okay?
So, now the people in the Levant need to
come together
and fend off this threat from the
Philistines. They also have these
neighbors, as well, these other cultures
that keep on attacking them. Okay?
So, these are extremely diverse people,
and so what they agree to do is elect a
king to lead them in war against the
Philistines.
And this person is named Saul, King
Saul.
All right.
And King Saul is a very good king. He's
a very good military leader. He's
helping the people
in the Levant fend off the Philistines
and aggressive neighbors.
Okay, so this is a military military
alliance.
King Saul
um employs a lot of mercenaries. And one
of these mercenaries is named David.
David.
David is an extremely
capable, charismatic
soldier
who develops a following.
David, as you can imagine, because he's
very charismatic, is also very
ambitious.
And eventually, he has a falling out
with Saul, okay? David is Saul's best
general, best soldier, but David is too
ambitious, and Saul sort of suspects
David.
So, what David does is he runs off and
joins the Philistines.
Okay? He's He's not He's not fighting
for the Philistines.
What's really important for us to
understand, and I I I know it's a hard
concept, okay? But borders, and
alliances, and allegiances are extremely
fluid at this time.
If it benefits me, I'll be I'll fight
for you.
But if it doesn't benefit me, then I'll
betray you, okay?
There are different factions within all
alliances.
Israel, Philistines are divided among
different ethnic groups.
The The people in the Levant are divided
into different political factions. You
know, you have these hill people, you
have these nomads, you have um these
foreign mercenaries, and they're
fighting for different reasons.
So, these alliances are always shifting,
okay?
So, David's
um
goes off and fights for the Philistines.
King Saul and his sons are eventually
killed in battle.
And David sees a political opening. So,
he turns
back into the Levant, and he starts to
politically maneuver to be the new king.
Okay?
And
um his power His power power base is in
the place called Hebron, or in south um
the Levant.
But the house of Saul is still around.
And so, there's a civil war now going
on.
And eventually David triumphs.
And then David's able to unite
these people, and he creates a new
nation called Israel.
All right?
And then Israel is able under David's
leadership is able to um basically
um put down any aggressions from its
neighbors. And they're able to build an
empire. A small empire, okay? Nowhere
near Egypt, but it's an empire.
All right?
So,
this is what we know from the
archaeological record.
But, David is so charismatic
that when he dies, his son Solomon is
not able to hold the empire together.
So,
uh what happens is Israel
divides into the northern kingdom
and Judah.
Which is where the house of David is.
Okay?
Now, again, the Levant
is a very important strategic location.
So,
as these empires, major empires, start
to consolidate their power, they want to
take over the Levant, okay? So, who So,
the Syrian empire
comes in and destroys the northern
kingdom.
And then eventually, the Babylonian
empire
will come in and destroy Judah.
Okay? The Bab- But, the Babylonians will
take the Israelite elite, bas- basically
the royalty, and force them to go to
Babylon, where they will be held as
hostages or captives.
Eventually,
what will happen next is the Persian
empire
will come
and defeat Babylon.
And what they do next is very
interesting.
They decide they will release
these Israelite elite,
ha- have them return
to Jerusalem and Israel and have them
govern
the Levant
based on
to
and have them govern the Levant, okay?
Does that make sense?
And it is only at this point that we get
the term Jews.
Okay? This is a Persian idea, the Jews.
Before they called the Israelites.
And
this is about 500 BC, okay? 500 BC.
And now we have a radical departure
from
the tradition, okay? And so I'll explain
three major differences.
And then I'll explain
uh I'll go into detail about these
differences in future classes, okay?
The first major difference is
Israel
uh under Israelites, it's a very it's a
polytheistic
religion.
They don't They have one god, Yahweh,
but Yahweh but they also have a pantheon
of gods, which is the same which is true
for every other religion, right? There's
a pantheon of gods. Yahweh's at at the
top, but they also celebrate other gods
like uh
Baal and Asherah, okay? We know because
they're written down in the Bible.
So, we know at this point Israel is
still a polytheistic religion.
But after the Persian
um but after the Persian Empire returns
them to Jerusalem, they became a
monotheistic
um uh religion or the beginnings of a
monotheistic religion. Why? Because
when the when the Jews are
released from captivity by the Persians,
their religion
merges with that of the Persian religion
called Zoroastrianism.
And Zoroastrianism is a dualistic
religion, okay? Meaning there's good and
evil.
So, that's the first major difference.
The At the beginning, the Bible was very
much a polytheistic religion, and then
after
uh the Israelites became the Jews, it
became
money monotheistic, okay?
Second big difference is this. Second
big difference is
during this time, the people with the
power in Israel were the kings, okay?
The monarchy.
But after
uh the
uh 500 BCE,
the Jews decided they don't want any
kings. And they couldn't have kings
because uh their overlords were the
Persians, right? So, the center of power
became the priesthood.
Okay?
The priests.
The people with the absolute authority
are the priests,
not the kings.
There are kings, but the kings are are
not subservient to the priests who speak
on behalf of Yahweh.
Okay? Because now it's a monotheistic
religion.
And then there's one other difference.
The The other difference is, remember,
at this point they're polytheistic
polytheistic and they're kings, okay?
Which means they are tolerant.
They're welcoming of other religions,
right? Because you're polytheistic. But
also, as kings, you need to establish
diplomatic alliances with other
countries who have different religions,
right? So, when you marry
uh someone
uh from another political dynasty, you
also are marrying into that religion.
Does that make sense?
So, Israel under the kings is a very
tolerant religion.
But if you're run by priests,
right? You become intolerant.
Because you insist that your religion
is the best.
Okay?
And that's why
after the Persians lost control and the
Greeks came in to the Levant,
uh this is the the solution empire,
okay?
The Jews rebelled against the Greeks
because the Greeks were polytheistic and
and the Jews considered themselves
monotheistic, okay? They refused to
acknowledge the culture and the religion
of the Greeks.
And then things got really real bad when
the Romans came in.
Okay? Does that make sense?
Okay, so this is the history
of
the
Jewish people
up until the birth of Jesus, okay?
Any questions so far?
Do you guys Do you guys understand
what's happening?
How did the Bronze Age collapse?
Excuse me?
Like how did the Bronze Age collapse?
Okay. Um
so how did the Bronze Age collapse?
Okay, we talked about this, okay? We
don't know why it collapsed. The
um mainstream academic understanding is
it's a perfect sto- It was a perfect
storm of several factors including
climate change,
including
um civil unrest,
including natural disasters like
earthquakes,
okay? Including
um competition among empires.
What's important to understand is when
you talk about Bronze Age collapse,
it we're really talking about about
basically this area. If you go east to
Mesopotamia where the neo where sorry
where the Assyrians and the Babylonians
are, they're fine.
Okay? And it's why the Bronze Age
collapse that allowed the Assyrians and
the and the Babylonians to eventually
become uh world powers.
So, um the Bronze Age collapse was not a
global phenomenon. It was a localized
phenomenon to the Mediterranean.
Okay? But, why the Bronze Age collapse
is important is because the Bronze Age
collapse will give us Greek
civilization, Homer, and Plato, okay?
It will also give us the Bible.
Right? Because if you If you look at
this history,
Israel would not have come into being
without the Bronze Age collapse.
Egypt or the Hittites would continue to
control the Levant.
All right? And it's important to
understand the Greeks and the Bible are
the basis, the two fundamental pillars
of Western civilization.
You understand? That's why Westerners
are so fascinated by the Bronze Age
collapse because
in their minds, the Bronze Age collapse
is part of God's divine plan or desire
to create classical Greece
and the the nation of Israel
so that his vision for the world can be
achieved through Jesus.
Okay?
Yep.
Yeah, that's fine. Yeah.
Okay.
So, that's a good question. So, the
argument I'm I'm trying to make up make
make to you is
the Bible says Abraham is a patriarch of
the Israelites.
But, the historical record the the
historical record is
we purely have evidence of David.
We we have absolutely no evidence of
anything before David.
Okay?
So,
I think David is a founder of the nation
of Israel not Abraham.
Next class I I will explain to you why
they constructed this mythology, okay?
All right, but I but first I want to
give you a broad overview.
All right, next class I will explain to
you
where these ideas Abraham and Moses came
from.
It will make sense when when I when I
explain to you.
Okay? But do you do you guys do you guys
have any more questions before I go on?
Yep.
Okay. Right, okay. Okay.
So, um
uh what happened with during the Persian
period, right? Okay. So, at this point
the religion of Israel is no different
from the local areas. It's polytheistic
it's it's a it's a polytheistic religion
with a pantheon of gods, okay? And maybe
Yahweh's at the top
or maybe Yahweh's coequal, okay? We
don't know.
And at this point
there are many divergent religions.
Okay?
But what happens is Babylon
conquers Jerusalem and then the Jews are
sent in exile.
So, now the religion is sent overseas
and it's the religion is detached from
the culture and the people. Does that
make sense?
And what we know is when you do that,
when you when you detach the religion
and you put it into a place
that has no interactions with the local
people and the culture, it becomes much
more
uh fanatical. It much it becomes much
more focused
and fanatical.
Okay, do you understand?
Okay? Do you do you understand? Because
if it's in Israel and the different
cultures, the religion has to be
tolerant and um
please different factions among the
people.
Okay? Does that make sense?
But once this religion goes off to
Babylon, it's now divorced from the
people, from the local reality. So the
elite can design it the way that they
think is most appropriate. And we call
that fanatical.
Does that make sense?
So an example of this, okay,
um it's a bad analogy, but but maybe
this will help you.
Right now you're not sure what it means
to be Chinese.
Okay? You're Chinese, but Chinese in
China is a very fluid,
uh very uh diverse
identity.
When you go off to America,
right?
Then you have much con- more concrete,
much more clear understanding of what it
means to be Chinese. Your Chinese
identity becomes much more formed. Does
that make sense?
Okay? The same thing with religion.
Within Israel itself, the religion is
constantly changing. It's very fluid.
But when they're off to Babylon, they
they have to use religion to survive as
a people, as an identity. And so it
becomes much more um formed, okay? Much
more concrete.
Does that make sense?
And then what happens is
as it's
now that's much more concrete,
it now interacts with Zoroastrianism,
which is the religion of the Persians.
And and at this point, the religion
becomes
um basically what it is today.
Okay?
Um
so, I I'm sorry. I don't I I don't think
I've explained this clearly clearly to
you, but I want to wait until we get to
this period, okay? Right now Right now
I'm just giving you the like a broad
overview.
Okay? Any more questions before I begin?
I put before I continue.
All right.
Now, I want to talk about the Bible,
okay? Because
the Bible
is the mythology. It's a collective
memory
of the Israelites, okay?
And
so
I'm going to I'm going to discuss why
the Bible was first created in this
class. And what I'll What I'll explain
to you is
the Bible was first created in order to
explain and just justify and create
legitimacy for David.
Okay? This is what we call an apology.
And this is a very common practice.
The idea is this.
Most kings, every king
obtains power through
um
really nefarious means, right? They
either kill a lot of people to obtain
power, or maybe the younger brother
kills the older brother to usurp the
throne, okay? Usually, kingship requires
uh ruthlessness.
But the problem is when you're ruthless,
you have a legitimacy problem.
Right? So, the way to that most kings
resolve this the issue is by sponsoring
writings
or apology to explain why he or she is
king. And the answer usually is
because God willed it so. Because I had
no choice in the matter. I'm not
ambitious. I was not at all ambitious.
But the circumstances
forced my hand
to save my people, to do God's work, I
had to kill my brother. I had to kill my
enemies,
even though I myself
am not a violent person. Okay? That's
usually how the apology goes. Okay?
So, remember
back at this point
the very idea of writing
it is new is it's a new technology, but
it's also very expensive technology,
meaning you need to buy the materials,
okay? Which which are rare, but you also
need the people
to be able to write, okay? And they're
also very expensive. You basically
needed to be able to support a team of
scribes to create any work of fiction.
So, writing back then is like movie
making today.
Okay? It's a very expensive
um endeavor that was usually sponsored
by the king in order to justify
um or explain why he is king. In order
to create legitimacy.
Okay? Does that make sense?
So, the Bible was created first as an
apology for David
and explains why the house of house of
David is now in charge of Israel.
But, as we discussed
okay?
Eventually, the house of David
Israel divides into two nations.
Now, the house of David the the Bible
goes with the house with house of Judah,
okay? To to Judah.
But, the northern kingdom now needs its
own mythology, its own Bible.
Right?
And so, a second Bible was created.
The people who are in charge of the
Bible
uh the priest class are interested in
promoting their own
um
interests, mainly in the points of
ritual.
It doesn't make sense?
Like what are rituals? Why do we need
them? Why are priests important?
Then you have um people
at this point in the Babylonian
captivity looking back
at the history of Israel and trying to
figure out why the house of David
collapsed. And their answer is because
the Israelites refused to follow the
will of God.
Because the Israelites became
polytheistic or they became immoral,
okay?
Does that make sense?
In other words, the Bible at this point
are divided into like four major
factions or schools.
Okay? The school that supports the house
of David, the legitimacy of the house of
David is called the J school.
Okay? The J school.
Don't worry about this. I'll explain to
you next class what these things mean.
The people who support the northern
kingdom as a legitimate house
of Israel is called the E school. E.
The school that supports the
uh power of the priests always called
the P school, okay? For priests.
And then
the school that tries to go back in
history and examine why Israel uh failed
um and which believe
it's because the Israelites betrayed
God. This is These people are what we
call the D school. Okay? The D school.
So E, G, P, and D. And these are just
four of the major schools. There are
other schools as well.
All right? And so at this point, the
Bible is divided into like four major
schools or documents
controlled by different factions.
When the Persians
take over, okay, they insisted, "You
need one religion, guys. You need one
document."
And so, all four were put together
to create the Bible.
Well, the way the way they did it
was very interesting.
All they did was just
put them put them together, okay? You
understand?
So,
you have So, if you read the Bible, it's
like A B C D A B C D.
Okay? So, one line is from the E score,
the next line is from the J score, the
other line is from the P score. It's
very confusing to read. If you don't
understand this history, it is
impossible for you to read the Bible.
I'm not sure if you've tried to read the
Bible. It's not readable.
Okay?
So, why would they do this?
Why would they just put all four texts
together without major editing
or revisions? Why? Okay, do you do you
guys know?
Why would they do that? It's very I
mean, they just made a complete mess of
the Bible.
But why would they do that?
Okay.
Okay. So, let me explain.
The first major reason is most people
didn't read or write back then.
So, the Bible itself didn't really
matter. What mattered was the oral
explanation of a Bible controlled by the
priest class. Does that make sense?
The people didn't read the Bible.
So, how the Bible was actually written
was not that important. It was important
um for the priest to have access to the
Bible.
Okay, but the people didn't actually
read the Bible. That's the first reason.
The second, more important reason is
because the Bible is political
real estate.
I want you to remember this idea, okay?
It is the most valuable political real
estate in the world.
Everyone wants to be in the Bible
because to be in the Bible gives you
legitimacy. Gives you power.
Right?
So,
if you're a king and you have four sons
who all want to be king, well,
your best solution is divide the kingdom
among the four sons, right? Same with
the Bible. You have four extremely
powerful schools and political factions.
So, the
the best way to resolve the issue is
just to say, "Listen,
we'll put you all in the Bible together,
okay?"
Like
and you when you merge them,
it's a lot easier
than if you just try to do it
um
by order, okay?
Like E school goes first and then J
school then P school then D school,
okay? They just put them all together.
Does that make sense?
Okay, so this is a very important idea.
The Bible is the most is the most
valuable political real estate in the
world.
Everyone wants to be in there.
And what ideas are you can find in there
will ultimately shape human history.
Okay?
Any questions so far before I before I
continue?
All right. So, the last thing I want to
talk about today
is the apology of David, which is the
beginning of the Bible.
Okay.
Um
So,
when kings come to power, they have
three major problems, right?
The first major problem is legitimacy.
What gives you the right to be king?
Okay?
Second problem
is the idea of the identity.
And this is a huge
for the Israelites because the
Israelites it's a multicultural
entity.
You have people speaking different
languages, different cultures. They have
They practice different cultures, they
practice different religions. So now you
need to create an identity
that everyone accepts.
Okay? The third thing is
differentiation.
You need not only for these people to
get along, but you need them You need to
get them to divorce their former
culture.
Does that make sense?
Cuz you have Egyptian priests in there.
You have to tell these Egyptian priests,
you're now Israelites and you're not
Egyptian anymore.
And the example that we use for this
um is Augustus Caesar
and the writing of the Aeneid.
Okay? Remember the Aeneid, it's a book
about a character named Aeneas.
And it provides political legitimacy to
Augustus Caesar because Augustus Caesar
is a direct descendant of Aeneas who is
the founder of Rome.
Also, what the Aeneid said is
Augustus Caesar is the end point of
Roman history. Everything before
Augustus Caesar led to him.
Augustus Caesar is like the Jesus of
Rome, okay? He's the salvation and he's
the redemption of Rome.
Okay, that's what the Aeneid the Aeneid
does, okay? Second Second thing about
the Aeneid is
it creates a new Roman identity that's
that focuses on piety,
loyalty over liberty.
Remember the problem
uh for Augustus Caesar was Romans didn't
like kings.
Well, now he's a king.
So how do you get people to obey? Well,
you tell them piety is more important
than liberty.
All right?
The third idea
is
the Aeneid, remember, it's anti-Greek.
The problem for Rome at the time was
Greek culture was vastly superior to
Roman culture.
And so a lot of Romans were adopting
Greek cultural practice like Mark
Antony.
And so uh the Aeneid said
Greek culture is like the Trojan horse.
If you let into your city
Greek culture will
corrupt you and destroy you.
Okay?
So
guess what, guys?
Every king has to resolve all three
issues, okay? Legitimacy, identity, and
differentiation.
And that's what David is trying to do
with the Bible.
Okay.
So let's So I'll give you three
examples.
Three stories from the Bible
that illustrate
um David's
quest for legitimacy.
Next class, we'll talk about
um identity and differentiation and how
the Bible achieves that, okay?
But this this class
I want to focus on legitimacy.
So
now that David is king
a lot of people don't think he's
legitimate.
Why? Because he ruthlessly
tried to usurp the throne from Saul,
right? Saul is the king that everyone
picked or elected.
And he was a good king.
He was good at war. He was someone that
most people
um liked.
And David took stole the throne throne
from him, okay?
So now what is David's problem now that
he has a throne?
Others will try to steal it from him,
right? You understand?
Because if you, David, are if you set
the precedent, if you
um steal the throne, then others are now
empowered to steal the throne from you
as well.
Okay? So, the first thing the Bible
does, the apology for David does, is
show us David
loved Saul. He was not at all ambitious.
He cared
only for the well-being of his king.
Okay? And so, one story that is
illustrates this. There are actually
many, many stories in the Bible that
does this. But, one story that
illustrates this is this.
So, Saul thinks David's trying to kill
him. So, he's chasing after David with
his army.
Okay? Trying to kill David and his
followers.
One uh one day, Saul is alone in a cave
praying to God
for deliverance.
David sees Saul alone and and he sneaks
up behind Saul.
Then, he takes his sword and cuts
a piece of Saul's
uh clothing.
Okay? And then, David disappears.
Saul leaves the cave, and then David
rushes to him and says, "Saul, my king,
I beg of you. Give me a second. Let me
explain to you.
Back then in the cave, I could have
killed you. This is a piece of clothing
to prove I could have killed you, but I
didn't because I love you. Because I'm
loyal to you. I would never kill you."
And then, Saul says, "Oh, this is this
is proof
that you were you never meant to kill
me. Okay?" And this is a story in the
Bible.
Um obviously, this story cannot be true,
okay? But, this is what the Bible's
trying to do. It's trying to first show
us
that David is not at all ambitious.
In fact, the entire apology of David is
focused on the lack of ambition of
David.
Okay?
So, that's the first story. Let's look
at the second story, okay? The second
story is this.
Saul is dead, and his son, who's a young
man,
um comes into the throne.
There's a general named Abner, okay?
Abner,
who was loyal to Saul, but now that Saul
is dead, and David is very popular among
the people, Abner sees the political
winds changing, and Abner tries to align
himself with David. So, Abner writes a
long letter to David and saying,
"Listen,
I will swear loyalty to you,
and will end the civil war between the
house of Saul and the house of David.
You will unite Israel."
And then David writes back and says,
"Yeah, come to my um come to me. We'll
have I'll I'll I'll give you a feast,
and then we'll be friends."
And so, Abner comes, David gives him a
feast, and then as Abner leaves,
he runs into um David's general named
Joab, Joab.
And Joab and Abner go a long way back,
okay? They were friends, they were
enemies. Abner killed Joab's brother.
And in an act of anger, Joab
stabs Abner to death, okay? And Abner is
dead.
And once Abner is dead,
the house of Saul basically gives up,
and David is able to unite
um Israel.
Okay? Now, that's the story in the
Bible.
David is so angry by this that he curses
Joab, and he and he gives Abner
a great funeral.
Right?
Because David
does not does not want to betray his
friends.
Why is this story
wrong or
completely made up. It's not made up,
but it's
it's what we call spin, right?
Clearly,
Abner and David had
um a feast together, and clearly Joab
killed Abner.
But why is the Bible version of of of
this event
wrong or incorrect?
It can't be true.
You guys know?
Okay, this is hard, okay?
But
the reason is this. If you're David and
you're king,
which person in the world are you most
afraid of?
If you're the king, there's a person in
this world you're most afraid of or
you're most suspicious of. Who is that
person?
Hm?
Abner.
Okay, yeah, he is suspicious of Abner,
but in general, you should be suspicious
of Joab, right? Cuz Joab has access to
your army.
Abner's your enemy, but Joab has access
to your army. So if Joab wants to betray
you, he could.
Okay?
So in other words, because David is most
suspicious of Joab, if Joab were ever to
act independently,
then David would would would need to
kill him. Does that make sense? And in
this circumstance, Joab acted
independently.
David told Joab Abner was an honored
guest, and Joab didn't care.
He was angry about the death of his
brother, and he kills Abner. This cannot
possibly be true. You understand?
Joab had to kill Abner because he was
ordered to by David.
Right?
Now now why would David want Abner to be
killed?
Because
in his mind he thinks, "Oh, if Abner can
can can betray the house of Saul, he can
also betrayed the house of David. He is
an ambitious man.
And why would he think like that?
Why would David come to this conclusion?
Because he himself is like that. Do you
understand?
He He himself betrayed Saul.
So, he's very very
careful or cautious about people who
betray their leaders.
Right?
Abner betrayed the house of Saul,
and it was very likely that he would
betray David at some point as well. And
so, David had to have him killed.
Right?
But,
he could not say this publicly.
Because if you if you if you were to say
this publicly, it would show
he in the fact knew this because he
betrayed Saul. Does that make sense?
The the logic of this?
Okay? But, you can see how wonderful the
spin is. It's almost impossible
to see the truth from this, right?
If you're a person, you know, okay, um
David uh
um
and you know that Joab killed Abner, and
you were told the story, you would
believe the story. It's just because
Abner was angry
that he killed uh sorry, it was it it
was just because Joab was angry he
killed Abner. Okay, you believe that,
right?
But, you think about it,
it can't be true, okay?
Now, I'm going to give you one more
story.
And this story is actually even harder
to figure out because of the spin.
Okay?
Now that um David is king of Israel,
Israel has many enemies, so his armies
are always at war. Okay?
One day, David is
on the rooftop of his house. So, and
this This Israel is not a very rich
place, okay? So, these these are not
palaces, they're just houses, okay? And
so, David is strolling on his rooftop
and across
from him is a woman named Bathsheba.
Bathsheba.
And she's bathing naked. And David is
overcome with lust. He's like, "I must
have this woman." Okay? And he's king,
he orders his servant to go get her, she
comes, they have sex.
Okay? The problem is, when they have
sex,
Bathsheba gets pregnant, okay? The
problem now is, Bathsheba is married to
a man named Uriah
the Hittite.
And Uriah the Hittite is one of David's
best soldiers and he's fighting
for David and Israel
somewhere else.
So, David's like, "Oh, this is a problem
because once Uriah comes home and he
finds Bathsheba has a new child, he's
going to know it's not his. So, either
he's going to kill her or he's going to
figure out it's David and come kill him,
okay?"
So, David, being very clever, has a
solution to this.
He invites
Uriah back home.
Okay? So, Uriah comes home from the war
and Uriah thinks, "Oh, the king has
called for me. Therefore, it's an
emergency." Okay? So, he rushes back
and David meets Uriah at his house and
David says, "Listen, Uriah, you've been
doing such a great job.
Um you're such a great soldier, you're
so loyal. I want to give you a vacation.
Go home and be with your wife."
And Uriah is like,
"Uh my king,
my comrades are dying, they're starving
out in the battlefield. I cannot abandon
them. How can I find pleasure in my wife
when my friends
are suffering? I refuse to go home. I
will not go home until the battle is
won."
And David
tries his best, but he can't convince
Uriah to go home.
So then David
tells Uriah, "You're such a great
soldier. You're so loyal. I'm so happy
and proud that you fight for me." And he
gives Uriah a letter
to his general, uh
Joab, okay? And the letter instructs
Joab to kill Uriah.
He Joab will send Uriah with his
soldiers out in the battlefield,
and then at the last minute Joab will
recall his soldiers, leaving Joab by
himself. At this point, the enemies will
swarm Uriah and kill Uriah.
And that's what happens.
And once Uriah is dead, David marries
Bathsheba.
And they have and they're about to have
a child together.
At this point,
David is visited by a prophet named
Nathan.
And Nathan says to
David, "I want to ask you a question."
And David says, "Sure, go ahead."
Nathan says, "Let's imagine there are
two shepherds. There's a rich shepherd
with 100 sheep, and there's a poor
shepherd with two sheep.
There's a
traveler, a foreign guest,
who comes into town, and the rich
shepherd wants to honor him with a
feast.
The rich shepherd The rich shepherd
steals the poor man's sheep to feed the
traveler.
Who's in the wrong?" And David says, "Of
course the rich shepherd is in the
wrong." He's indignant. He's angry. How
could a man be so unrighteous as to
steal another man's sheep?
And then Nathan says, "You, David, are
the rich shepherd. You have violated
God's law. You're are in the wrong.
And as punishment, God will take away
your son or your child with Bathsheba.
And that's what happens. And
David is goes into mourning, okay? He is
distraught, he's depressed. And he
writes a lot of poetry.
Okay. So, this is a very awful story.
And this is a story that has captured
the imagination
of
everyone for 1,000 years.
But it's complete
spin.
This is not what happened, okay?
How do we know?
Okay. First thing is this.
Nathan says to David, "You have stolen a
man's shepherd." Uh sorry, "You have
stolen a man's wife. Therefore, you're
in the wrong."
What's What's the problem with this
logic?
What is David's crime? Real crime.
Guys,
he killed Uriah.
Right? You understand? You You've
forgotten this fact.
He had Uriah killed.
That's the real crime. He killed Uriah.
Yeah, he slept with Bathsheba. That's
bad, but it's much worse if you murder
someone, okay?
So, another question then is,
why would he murder Uriah?
Why not just talk to him honestly and
say, "Uriah, I'm sorry. I love your
wife.
I I had sex with her. I'm sorry." Why
did he Why did David ha- have to have
have to get Uriah killed?
Why was Uriah killed?
Yeah, because the loyal The army is
loyal to Uriah, right?
So, why would David fear Uriah?
Because Uriah is is a popular, brave
soldier, just like David.
And David used his popularity in order
to usurp the throne from Saul, right?
Therefore, David thinks Uriah could do
the same thing to me.
Therefore, I have to have have to get
him killed.
In other words, this Bathsheba thing
must have come later to disguise
the fact
that David killed Uriah because he
feared Uriah's popularity. Does that
make sense?
Right? Do you see how clever this story
is?
The historical truth must have been
David feared Uriah's popularity.
And he needed to get rid of Uriah, so he
can have this plan.
And then, after he killed Uriah, he
needed he needed to explain to his army,
okay,
who loved Uriah,
why this happened. And then, they were
just like, "Oh, because I fell in love
with his wife. I couldn't control
myself. I'm just a man."
Okay? God is God, I'm a man. I'm a king.
I can't be God. I can't control my
emotions.
Right?
Does that make sense?
But
the irony of this is because
David is working so hard to disguise
his
ruthlessness,
he's creating
very powerful literature.
He created a very powerful story that
has captured the imagination
of readers for a long time. If you think
about it, you think a lot about the
story, it unleashes a lot of ideas in
you.
Okay?
You have to ask yourself, what is man?
What is God?
Are we capable of controlling our
emotions?
So, in other words, this story is
extremely well constructed
that
inspires you to imagine your own
personal
and emotional
and moral life.
We call this literature.
Right?
So,
guys, it's no
coincidence that today
the Jewish people are the most creative
people in the world. When you go to
America for university,
uh most of your professors are Jewish.
Most of the best things in the world are
Jewish. These past 200 years, there've
been three revolutionary thinkers.
Karl Marx,
uh Albert Einstein,
and Sigmund Freud. They're all Jewish.
Who are who are stepped who are
who have been raised in the Jewish
tradition of asking deep questions about
what it means to be human.
Right? Does that make sense?
Okay, any questions
about this?
Okay, that's a good question, okay? So,
the question is why would people believe
this apology of of David? And well, the
answer is most most didn't believe the
apology of David, okay? Most were very
clear about David's ambitions.
But,
when you're king,
you need to
impose your reality on others, okay? So,
that's this is why this written.
And so,
um
it was written
for people who were part of David's
political coalition. Do you understand?
His enemies wouldn't believe this,
right? But, it was meant It was
basically meant to appease or convince
those who want to believe David.
Does that make sense?
Okay, spin. And it's it's it happens
today, guys. When you watch the news,
it's spin.
Right? It's It's a story in reality.
And so, most people will believe the
media, right? There are some people who
will never believe the media.
Like I I don't believe any anything the
media tells me, whether it's Chinese
media or American media. I I know a lot
of history to understand
the media is is distorting reality.
Okay? But, uh most people will will
believe this because they have
absolutely no interest in not believing
it, right? David's king. If you don't
believe it, then you have to then you
have to believe your king is a murderer.
Okay? Does that make sense?
Yeah. Yeah, Echo?
What's the mainstream understanding of
this story?
Oh, yeah. That's a good question. Okay,
I Yeah. This is really important. What's
the mainstream understanding of the
story?
So, the mainstream understanding of the
story is it has to be true. Why? Because
it puts David in a bad light.
Do you understand?
And it shows the genius of David because
David
is wrestling with his own morality.
David is being honest.
Right? So, the mainstream understanding
is David is a poet king.
He's a man who prays constantly
and
engages in a process of self-reflection.
And that's what makes David great.
Right? He's constantly praying to God.
In fact, the Bible just goes on
endlessly about this, how David is
constantly in communication with God.
And in this communication, he's praying
and asking for light for for truth in
his own weaknesses, okay? To be
delivered from his failings as a man.
And the Bathsheba Bathsheba story is
emblematic
um about this because why would a man
make this up, right?
Well, I've told you why, but most
scholars don't see that. Most scholars
think, "Okay, well, this Bathsheba story
puts David in the worst possible light.
Therefore, it must be true and therefore
it shows us David is a poor king who is
constantly thinking about his own moral
failings. And so, he's been an
inspiration
to his people."
Okay? That's the mainstream
understanding.
Okay? Any other questions?
Yep.
That's right.
Oh, okay. So, um the question is, if
people at that time were mainly
illiterate,
why was this written down? Or how would
they know the story? Okay? So,
um the idea is this. First of all, this
was written for the elite, for the
people around David to know what story
to tell people.
Does that make sense?
Okay? This is So, this was for internal
consumption
and this was to basically uh preserve
David's historical legacy.
So, maybe 20 years from now, when
everyone's dead, when people who knew
Uriah and Bathsheba were dead, well,
what
what is truth now? The truth is what
what what's been written down, okay?
That That's what they're saying,
"History is written by the writers."
Right? History is not written by the
winners. History is written by the
writers.
Right?
Okay? Does that make sense?
Okay? A- A- more questions?
Okay, great. So, next class
we'll continue the the Hebrew Bible,
okay?
Because it starts off as an apology for
David, but it evolves into a much larger
mythology, right? So, that's next class.